- So this weekend is WrestleMania
and it got me thinking about a wrestler
by the name of Bret The Hit Man Hart.
So you see Bret Hart was a wrestler
in the WWF, now WWE, for a very long time.
Originally as a tag team partner
of Jim The Anvil Neidhart,
known as The Hart Foundation
and he had a very nice career in the early
to mid 80s through into the late 80s
and then into the early 90s
and then in the early 90s he broke out
as an individual star and
he's now widely considered
probably one of the best 10
to 15 wrestlers of all time.
Why am I talking about
Bret The Hit Man Hart
in a video that's probably
predicated on thoughts
around business, it's because of this.
Bret Hart's nickname was
The Excellence of Execution
and I've been giving a
lot of thought lately
to where the world's at
right now and the lack
of people's understanding of
how much execution matters.
I've realized that I'm
not investing in as many
startups lately because
a lot of the people
have very nice ideas but
I've watched so many,
so many bright, brilliant,
hungry, ambitious,
talented 22- to 26-year-olds
in the last couple years
just completely fail
because they didn't have
the gut and or experience
and or nuances to navigate
through the execution
of what it took to build a
business or, more importantly,
the ability to adjust half-way through
as this world moves so
quickly that they're not able
to change their business
model when the world
changes on them based on the prominence
of how they launched their company.
See, I get a lot of emails
from friends on Facebook
like oh, my God, you're so lucky,
it all happened so fast.
It didn't happen fast.
I've been fucking
executing since I was 14.
In a Malcolm Gladwell
world of 10,000 hours
and you're an expert,
I put in 50,000 hours.
The reason I failed every
class is 'cause I was running
businesses since I was 14-years-old.
Everybody's like oh Wine
Library TV is such a phenomenon.
I ran Wine Library, a wine
retail and ecommerce business
from 1998 until early
2006 every single day
for 17 hours a day before
I started Wine Library TV
to get internet famous.
See, execution matters and
putting in the work matters.
Bret Hart grew up in a wrestling family.
He was eight and nine when
he was in The Squared Circle
every day getting thrown
around like a rag doll
by his older brothers and his dad.
Put in the work, execute,
and then you've got a shot.
Your ideas are cute and
all but without execution
most of you will fail.
It is time, in 2013, that we start getting
dramatically more
practical and start looking
at people that are 28, 29, 42, 49,
50, 57, and understand
yeah, maybe they don't know
what Snapchat is but their
execution value is high.